merci bernard je crois que c'est la
première fois qu'on lui dit bravo de
cette façon mais vous avez des marines
qui est avec nous ça va ma riner est
très bien berges ou bien jours voilà
bien sûr
les élections législatives ça commence
dimanche prochain avec le premier tour
mais les français de l'étranger ont
commencé à voter hier résultats les
candidats de la majorité présidentielle
sont arrivés en tête dans neuf
circonscriptions sur 11 à l'exception de
manuel valls l'ancien premier ministre a
été éliminée n'arrivant que troisième
dans la 5e circonscription
circonscription qui comprend notamment
l'espagne et le portugal
il est battu par le candidat de
l'alliance de la gauche renault le berre
et par stéphane vosges et à député
sortant et candidat dissident de la
majorité présidentielle dans un tweet il
appelle au rassemblement
ma famille politique doit se réunifier
derrière ma candidature mais elle doit
aussi prendre acte du message envoyé par
les électeurs un véritable
renouvellement de nos pratiques et de
nos personnels politiques
manuel valls a publié plusieurs messages
hier soir pour reconnaître sa défaite je
ne peux pas ignorer mon score et le fait
que ma candidature n'a pas convaincu
écrit-il quelques minutes avant de
supprimer son compte twitter il publie
un autre message laissant le fou sur son
avenir politique il m'appartient
lucidement d'en tirer les conséquences à
gauche on se réjouit de cette défaite de
l'ancien socialiste adios manuel valls
lance le maire écolo de grenoble eric
piolle bon débarras a renchéri le député
insoumis adrien cnas cui cui à chuke
vas-y bla blart chouf au cloud toc toc
toc toc toc pouf arrageois bla bla bla
bla mais ou à bla bla bla bla bla quizz
ou au foot ou abap stopped octobre tout
tout tout bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
se passe yep web la bla bla bla bla week
il joue au foot ou temps
eliya du soleil sur la france
brel
reste n'a pas d'importance mais je ferai
de matteo comme sorte de halle est
originale
car ce n'est que stoner je la
vois je ne sais pas si on va par gm
était au volant d'un kart gens partent
parce que moi j'ai chanté donc du coup
on va avoir du lot c'est elle pendant le
repas seuls les hommes sont autorisés à
manger assis
les femmes doivent rester debout et
s'occuper de la vaisselle et du ménage
avant de pouvoir manger à leur tour même
les jours de mariage ces règles dans
notre temps perdure
[Musique]
qu
est ce qu une fois
le lédat
le prince louis s'est à nouveau fait
remarquer lors du jubilé de la reine
elizabeth 2 hier lors de la parade le
fils de kate et william étaient
visiblement agacé par sa mère la scène
isolé et zoomer par un internaute cumule
plus de 10 millions de vues
des pitreries ajouter à cette séquence
déjà culte du garçon de 4 ans incommodé
par les avions de la royal air force
oui
batista
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après tout les mêmes
bon
okapi
m
quelle force de l'autre dérision grande
première pour laurent un tour de
contrôle des appels téléphoniques sa
valeur à huit la guerre si tout va bien
tout mieux à mon avis ça ne durera pas
sûr judicieux on est sous le charme
franchement magnifique couché avec
céline ça fait un gain de 2,4 je veux
dire une chose je ne veux pas aller tous
les jours vous cherchez en garde à vue
donc il va falloir que vous essayer de
contenir ses ardeurs des excuses et ce
couple d'américains on a reçu de la part
de disneyland paris pour avoir ruiné la
demande en mariage de ce touriste le
cadre était parfait me l'estrade sur
laquelle ils sont montés est interdite
au public pour des raisons de sécurité
d'où l'intervention d'un employé du parc
un moment inoubliable à sa façon
très tôt les fillettes gitane après
d'asservir les hommes à 7 ans ange ali
la petite soeur de miguel sait déjà qui
commande à la maison
je lui dis va me chercher un verre d'eau
l escalade la cuisine à prendre le verre
de loi me le ramène mais moi je suis
alors que je peux me lever et j'arrive
très bien à prendre le verre pour me
servir elle sait déjà pour un suspense